typify a great British classic
absolutely delicious
mince vegetables potatoes easy
Olive Oyl
minced lamb still the cover on the mince
and it gets rid of that unwanted fat
nothing worse than a greasy shepherd's
pie season
great onion
garlic once the vegetables are grated in
there they kiss integrate and almost
puree adding great flavor and that's the
secret behind a really good shepherd's
pie it's all in the mince what's the
sauce tomato puree
red wine
time Rosemarie right now the red wines
evaporated chicken stock in
I cook it out for three or four minutes
no more than that
potatoes mash season
egg yolks now
secret ingredient Parmesan cheese
in court generous for the parmesan
because that's what gets it really nice
and golden brown now deserve to sit on
top of my mints
fashion tip just be mama happy
for the top 18 to 20 minutes in the
other useful
the crispy topping you can see what that
deserves to be a great British classic
shepherd's pie done the most important
about filler beef one until do not slice
it thinly okay turn it round the slice
about an inch thick bread transformed
before your eyes flatbread with fennel
and feta simple delicious and ready to
eat in minutes